specific items that you're going to be
learning how to craft awesome you got to
get to that oh god to see that I could
give my fall
sons of anarchy you
now would you say as far as resources
any game like it's very scarce very
limit you have to be kind of competent
Oh escaped ambitious skin vicious
as far as on a multiplayer component is
if something days gone would ever
consider multiplayer component what is
something days gone would ever consider
which is great because a lot of games
right now always sometimes tack on you
know just curious if it was something
design choice that you were thinking
about but from a single player
standpoint that's one thing we feel
sonia's we got Studios they do well
that's that's their strengths and those
cinematic over the over the shoulder you
know really engrossing experiences so we
can expect more of that what day is gone
yeah stick it to the forum I like
still searching getting get a lot of
ammo a lot of stuff going on
look em they still looking there's no
trying to find things
now how far long would you say as far as
getting that uh that bike or that some
that's still something he's far away
from at this point in the there we go
so we still doing it and now mission
currently is fine loser
this game looks really good I have to
graphically
on the Pro HDR 4k all that good stuff
alright hey so there's our Waypoint
we're about 62 meters from that
health pack on the ground
oh here we go okay
I'm assuming this is a rival fashion
okay really okay sounds like a lot of
freaking of evolved
[Laughter]
or the rippers don't play
sold its own strong
we got to do what we got to do
all right so we got cover going on
adding a little bit of a stealth
mechanic
Tribble to see if we can save our boy
from the rivers creeping
right
to a diatom MJ let's go okay okay the
boss done did his thing save the guy
let's talk to our guy nice Wow that hand
is mess
[Music]
see if we can get him out of there
is he gonna tough it out all right there
you go get it boy get it man a ride he
didn't went through some things
nice alright
again I'll just love everything
cinematic story-driven
get immersed in the world kind of deal
and again you're gonna encounter this
kind of stuff a lot I'm assuming in days
more this is this kind of the essence of
some of the gameplay loop oh one other
question awesome
[Music]
I don't think to be determined okay we
say do they exist they're big characters
that we will encounter in the game nice
is our first look at some motorcycle
mechanics here
you know story-based like you gotta be
really stuff this is here's 300 okay Wow
and we've encountered problems and we've
encountered look at the sheer volume of
zombies going down your day was gone
wow that is intense
I mean just they might get that sheer
volume of NPCs bump on the screen is
pretty impressive Wow so would you say
again this is kind of like an open play
space what's his goal right now we're
trying to
Wow yeah get to it MJ
fatigue I can come in here and play
straps and figure out like a path you're
gonna run them through the barrels yes
Wow this is unique this is a very unique
mechanic and we are in trouble
[Laughter]
fight or flight and we are flight get on
top can we get on top of that trailer
can we do something
oh man it's not looking good it's
looking shaky we're going down baby good
mj's hotel so tell baby's healing no
chatting we go shouting seek refuge Wow
the intensity of the horde is wow it
really adds a level of tension in it
yeah you know you would have to
encounter more obviously more situations
like this we're just gonna have to keep
figuring out ways to deal with them
gotcha that's it words are all over the
world and you've really just got an
approach them and figure out how to deal
with it you kind of learned that through
the game
gotcha as you as you
this is awesome and I rely think this
part home is what really what sets days
going apart and again the way they
handle horth and MJ with this bike you
got get that together but but it is
really unique that is what separates
this from in my opinion any typical
zombie game you know it's this aspect is
very unique
oh boy I think that's gonna cut it so
any tips can we give MJ just maybe two
he could get past this portion here
like like these little corridors here
usually these are lined with